of a government jet which had brought
her from Washington the U.S House
speaker was whisked away to the hospital
in San Francisco where her husband is
being treated
it is a Wonder Paul Pelosi survived the
ordeal here inside their home in the
early hours of Friday morning
as the attacker entered through this
door breaking the glass with a hammer Mr
Pelosi who is 82 and was alone inside
managed to call 9-1-1 a dispatcher
praised for interpreting the urgency of
an unclear call
when officers arrived at just before 2
30 in the morning they witnessed the
attack we know he was struck at least
one time and that's what we know
we also know
based on our investigation at this point
that this was not a random act this was
intentional
and it's wrong
our elected officials are here to do the
business of their cities their counties
their states and this nation
their families don't sign up for this to
be harmed
and it is wrong
the suspect who has been named as 42
year old David de Pepe tried to tie Mr
Pelosi up and told officers at the scene
we're waiting for Nancy Nancy Pelosi is
the third most senior politician in
America second in line to the presidency
after the Vice President she is among
the most prominent of Democratic party
figures and a key supporter of Joe Biden
the chant was
where's Nancy where's Nancy where's
Nancy
this is Despicable
there's no place in America
there's too much violence political
violence
too much hatred
too much vitriol
the political climate here right now is
tense with the midterm elections just
over a week away the nation is bitterly
dangerously divided and those false
claims of a stolen election well they
linger and they agitate we don't yet
know precisely what the motive was for
this attack but the fact remains it is
the second time in two years that
speaker Pelosi has been the target
on the 6th of January last year she was
evacuated from her office on Capitol
Hill moments before a mob arrived
[Music]
security at their San Francisco home
wasn't High because speaker Pelosi
wasn't there a review will now consider
whether family members of high-profile
politicians do need protection too it
comes at a time when authorities are
warning the threat of targeted political
violence is growing Mark Stone Sky News
in Washington